hello CBS News viewers I'm dr. David
agus and we're here in the CBS this
morning
Toyota greenroom with Oscar Health CEO
and co-founder mario schlosser
his company Oscar is working to change
the health industry with technology
driven consumer focused services in the
insurance field found it in 2012 six
years ago and based in good old New York
City it has approximately 250,000
enrollees and more than 800 employees
Mario welcome to CBS it's really Givens
so obviously saying we're gonna upend
the insurance industry bring technology
new ways of focused toward the consumer
something that is you know all of us are
passionate about because every person in
this country has had difficulty with
health insurance whether it be on the
billing side the delivery side you name
it so this came about six years ago tell
us a little bit about just the story of
how you got from your issues to solving
them yeah at a high level I think
there's two issues with the US
healthcare system really it's too costly
we spend almost a fifth of our incomes
on health care as compared to 10% of GDP
or so when in other most other developed
countries and it's too confusing it's
the last industry where facts might be
more useful than a smartphone and so I'm
as fax FAA fa CT that's right exactly
that's right and so in 2012 I was going
through my wife's first pregnancy year
my son two and six years already
yesterday by the way thank you very much
and we were kind of having a navigates
this complicated healthcare system
trying to find a maternity ward in New
York City with a low enough c-section
rates trying to find the right of egy in
understanding what this will cost us and
all these kind of questions are go
through your mind when you were navigate
what should be a happy experience
pregnancy and we thought that the health
insurer is such a such a unique vantage
point in the healthcare system it has
really good visibility for data flowing
throughout the system and a good amount
of control over the dollars flowing
through the system as well it sets
reimbursement rates of providers it
members what it will reimburse for and
if you combine these two things and if
you could create insurance company
that's liked by people as opposed to not
liked by most people who use it it would
be potentially a very powerful impactful
force in the healthcare system and
that's what Oscar I think has become so
you and your co-founder Josh Kushner put
this together and it was named for
Josh's grandfather right great
grandfather great grandfather yeah he
emigrated in to over Ellis Islands I
think before World War two and the
immigration official talked with him you
know I can't spell your name it was
Joshua originally he's named after his
grandfather great-grandfather instead
I'm going to give the name Oscar and so
Josh's mother once commented when Josh
was in the ER after spending his ankle
playing basketball
that's this feels almost as Byzantine as
the immigration system back in those
days no that's how the name came about
that's great so obviously you've got a
doctor who wants to deliver care and
you've got a patient who wants care and
you sit in the middle so how do you make
that middle point for you actually
empowering for both ends of the spectrum
yeah we almost want to be we would like
to be the entry points to health care
for our members so really whatever issue
you have whatever question where you
have emerging in your minds we'd love
for members to reach out to us first if
you're looking for a new physician if
you have some kind of worry about some
pain you have whatever else check with
us first we would like to route you to
the right place of the healthcare system
that's a really important aspect of how
we build this you say we who is we we is
either our virtual telemedicine
physicians we've got a couple of dozen
physicians working for us directly
delivering telemedicine so you can chat
with them so the real physicians the
bots know exactly and you can see their
pictures and things like that so when
they chat with you when they talk to you
it is your consortium we reorganize the
way we do customer service in a way
that's six people at Oscar we'll cover
you as a member and whatever whenever
you chat with us you call us you will
get back to these six people and you see
you can the picture is their names and
their backgrounds and one of these six
people is a nurse and so when you call
for example when you chat with us and
you say something on the line
of what is my deductible what am I gonna
pay when I go to the doctor the answer
won't just be what the deductible is but
it'll be obviously what what it is and
then can we help you with the underlying
issue can we get you to the right doctor
can we make an appointment for you can
we solved the problem right then and
there in the conversation and being that
entry porins gives us t but you only of
really organizing the underlying health
care delivery system in a way that's I
think is quite unique so about 40% of
first time physician visits now in a
place like New York City a year we help
make the appointments we help get you to
the right physician and it's a
data-driven I mean are you saying listen
we're doing to this doc because they're
better for you or are you just saying
this doc is closer I mean it don't feel
data but it's that's again the other
superpower if you will of the insurance
company if correctly used we can see
obviously all of your health history we
can see the drugs you're on we can see
the lab tests you've you've had we show
those back to you of course in the
mobile application as well we share
those with a physician of course as well
but we also use them to really say okay
for your particular instance and issue
this physician might be the best one
quick example when my kids now four and
six years always had their tonsils taken
out so we were looking for the surgeon
who could best do this in New York and
it turns out there's a surgeon mont
sinaï who's doing a thousand
tonsillectomies and you know one or two
year period or so and so frequency
procedure and something as routine as
tonsillectomy is a good indicator of
quality of procedure and so I went to my
kids went to that surgeon and we were
happy with that so this kind of data
isn't really accessible to someone that
trying to be smart navigating the
healthcare system by him or herself but
we still sure can we can make it
available to you and help you manage
your health care in this way as you grow
your data will get better and better so
I mean speaking of that I mean you also
mention something a little bit scary
right is that you know you have our data
so you have our medical records you have
our lab data and then recently alphabet
the parent of Google just put three
hundred and seventy-five million dollars
into you so that brings fear into many
people's hearts when you say you Google
whoever have data related to our health
we view health on this pinnacle you know
it's our own private data so how are you
kind of teetering that line of
protecting our privacy
and at the same time using data for good
is an extremely important aspect of how
we organize in the company how we think
in the company and it's one reason why I
like being an insurance company we've
been highly highly regulated from the
very beginning and therefore making sure
we treat your data incredibly
confidentially and only ever use it to
increase the quality or the value of
your health care has been a given since
the very beginning we have tons of
protections around the fact that only
two people internally who should be
looking at the data actually look at
your data our caregivers or nurses or
customer service people we put security
around the physician applications as
well that we protect your data in a good
way and in my view actually in
healthcare right now we're suffering
from too much siloing into little
availability of data rather than too
much you still really can't oftentimes
on a physician by physician basis see
who's driving goods clinical outcomes
and who's not who's driving hi caustic
here who's very efficient at living
caustic here we still don't know for
many tests even how well they really
work in which situation from a position
point of view I remember one story and
personally a couple years ago my
daughter was born it's now four years
olds we went did one of those cell-free
DNA tests and she showed up with a
suspected condition 40:18 Edward
syndromes of you know will probably kill
her when she directly rare genetic
disease exactly right and so frantically
we started reading the literally at the
time three available medical papers on
the efficacy of this tests and I was
sort of like in the figures of these
papers and trying to figure out what
this suspected really meant from a
statistical point of view and it turns
out there was probably about a 60%
probability it was a false positive that
wasn't really being told to me by that
company that administered the test but
it was that way from these papers as far
as I could see and some she turned out
to be fine and so had we did we would we
have more data in the healthcare system
with more availability even from a
research point of view we could provide
better statistical metrics for our new
tests before but you're not really
designed for that I mean you're not
designed to
data in a systematic way with data
standards etc you're designed for
individual physicians they can collect
their own data on you and then you could
be a repository for that so it's gonna
be hard to actually use your data to
advance the field per se
well the ambition again the unique thing
we have as Oscar is that we have much
more member engagements than any other
insurance company out there who are
ember engagements it essentially means
when you utilize healthcare there's a
10x higher chance that you will go to
Oscar first talk to us first ask us for
advice use our care delivery even the
telemedicine service for example then
it's compared to anything she wants
company out there and for convenience
exactly right it's too hard to get to my
dock so I can just exactly right on your
app you push a button and one of our
doctors will call you about chat with
you or that physician will know how
clinically complex you are as a member
he or she will know what your health
history is what your needs are what
medications you are on how do we need
sort of like explain to you how to best
utilize the healthcare system and some
that does I think over time give us
unique insights into how to live a
better healthcare as well I think we are
in a unique position to again ask you
about are you getting better after
having a certain surgery or procedure
done in a way that can be very helpful
for then improving the way the
healthcare system functions
you mean the part that we don't control
directly as Oscar one of things I love
about what you're doing is you know
you're incentivizing people to do the
right thing and in our country you can
smoke you can sit all day be as larger
than one and then we as a society have
the obligation to pay for the healthcare
ramifications of your behavior you're
telling your patients your customers
what do you call them anyway members
your members that listen if you walk
number of steps I'll give you a discount
or I'll give you a refund that's a
remarkable thing to incentivize and I
certainly believe in that are you gonna
make it bigger that program absolutely I
think that's again a unique aspect of
being an insurance company we have a
fundamentally aligned business model
with the interests of the member if you
are healthier or get healthier more
quickly yeah healthy more quickly then
you know I
we're cost benefits as well and
therefore whatever we can invest in your
health ends up benefiting really all of
us and paying you to walk steps is the
very very beginning of that we can give
you a discount if you book an
appointment online we can overtime pay
physicians more if they see patients in
the same day basis we can extract
discounts from let's say radiology
centers if we send members there in off
peak hours and all these kind of things
that you are used to from any other
industry out there many other
consumer-driven is read that but that
into health care really hasn't hasn't
evolved so I guess one of the
difficulties if I were you and your
shoes running a company is that I can't
do what I want you've got all these
legislators involved in a radically
changing field as we see a for to be
care good Affordable Care bad let's
throw it out let's build it up how do
you navigate when you don't even know
what the sea is gonna be like where
you're going yeah
um very unique aspect again of being an
insurance company for sure we're I think
in New York State we were the first new
insurance company in twenty years or so
what I got grief that got licensed from
the green field in the commercial space
so there wasn't really a blueprint for
how we would be able to grow because
nobody tried or was just did try I think
it is too difficult to become an
insurance company there are and there
there weren't many entry window was one
of the powerful aspects to me from of
the Affordable Care Act was that
creating individual markets where we
could really go to people initially even
like us in overtime really from all
walks of life who want insurance want a
better health care experience and sell
directly to them and that's
individualization I think unleashes a
power in the health care system of
innovation of more competitor on the
system then you just didn't have before
and so that was an important catalyst
for us to get into the markets now how
do we navigate it I think to me the
number one thing is if we are building
something that members like if people
like to come to us if they think we're
solving their problems all the other
stuff is noise almost so we have to
obviously be smart about how which
markets do we go into how old is a
pricing work and things like that
we like others in the ACA marketplace
and to navigate the kind of starts to
stop service markets but we're at a
point now at six years in where members
really like dealing with us we grow by
in by word of mouth a tremendous amount
in cities we've been in for a while and
we actually also are able to manage our
medical loss ratio the kind of medical
cost divided by premiums we take in the
key metric of whether the insurance can
be as well run to the point where it's
really compared with other insurance
companies and so on it's all kind of
working together now in a very nice way
that's fair I mean what's interesting
right I mean you have to ask this
question when you talk to you is right
you have a co-founder whose
brother-in-law is the son-in-law of the
president United States if a president
United States who says we're gonna get
rid of Affordable Care Act you were
built in the era of Affordable Care Act
there seems to be this push in this pull
and obviously you know you guys are
trying to look forward and say where is
health care going to be and you're
expanding you're going into new states
how do you put them all together though
I mean how do you are you lobbying are
you out there trying to make health care
go a direction that you think is right
as a company and so we tell the story of
why we think individualization in the
health care market is very important as
loudly as we can you know we have blog
posts about that there's a recent Wall
Street Journal editorial that julik Lyon
one of the people that asked her Rhodes
with the professor from our business
school hurt slinger about how
individualization consumerization can
work and I love that least otherwise a
great thank you that's good well
definitely tell him I I love that so and
some the so we tell those stories loudly
as we can and some we tell the stories
to people who ask us for advice as well
and on Capitol Hill but we are
completely independent from any kind of
connection there might be on the back
ends that's never even entered the
equation of of my thinking because
fundamentally I think we are we're
pushing for something that that will be
good for the healthcare system is needed
for the health care system where many
observers agree the sort of like odds
employer-based system we've had in the
US since World War two is an anachronism
is a thing of the past something has
been holding us back in developing a
more competitive
and so as long as we can tell that story
probably loudly I think we're we're
getting somewhere I don't mean looking
I'm looking on the outside right you
have one care group that you built in
Brooklyn yep and you know if somebody's
on your plan for four years
you're not incentivized to care about
their health care in 10 or 20 years so
how do we change America so we're not
switching plans every three or four or
five years and you're incentivized from
my long-term care go on lipitor today
for example because it's gonna help you
20 years now most insurance companies
don't care about twenty years from now
how do we align the incentives and this
is the single biggest question I think
we have in how to redesign your
healthcare system there's this very
simple answer if you give individuals a
chance to buy their own health care and
I say this in the broadest possible
sense you know I always almost view
Oscar as a subscription package for
health care not a health insurance plan
you know a years on a monthly basis and
we organize the health care system for
you in the best possible way so if we
give individuals the chance to buy that
one health care with might be pre-tax
dollars from the employer with you know
it just ace HRA accounts and those all
kinds of very different ways to do it's
that's we're then unleash innovation and
ability for us and others really say if
we do a nice job in managing your health
care you'll stick with us for 50 years
and then the incentives become really
fully alliance that's the place you want
to we want to be adds we always
internally in the company say we're
developing our technology we're
developing our products to the point
where members like us so much that they
want to stick with us for 50 years and
that's in the pay attention to us to our
advice and to our incentives that we
give them so that actually they might
think about change my behavior in a way
that they will be healthy in 50 years
from now that's the whole word insurance
makes no sense right you're not an
insurance company I mean you're trying
to be a lifestyle company you're trying
to encourage the right lifestyle educate
incentivize that's not insurance and the
insurance function in that is an
important aspects because again it gives
us visibility to the data and control of
the incentives but yeah that's the
ambition that's the overarching goal for
sure and do people like us do they make
different choices
based on advice we give them incentives
we give them and will they be healthier
in many years to come do you have a
special ops group or something who is
sitting there and looking at new
technologies should I sequence the DNA
of every patient and tell them what
diseases will happen and prevent them
should I use this kind of scanner
instead of that kind of scanner are
there all these tech people sitting in
our corner trying to advise so we don't
try to do this in a special ops group we
try to do this with everybody but across
the company I think one of the most
unique aspects what Oscar is that we
still are at the very beginning of
building all of this outs and we've
built our entire lis internal
infrastructure so claims medical
management's you know medical outreach
is all totally internally builds and it
now gives as an ability of moving very
very quickly when we see new ideas see
new potential partners and so we want
everybody at Oscar every engineer every
condition every physician to say I
discovered an interesting service over
here I guess I saw a great app over
there I saw a great physician partner
over there can we incorporate that into
our service and that should needs to be
across the entire business and yes every
single day there's a new idea coming
from somewhere and some in the system
that we think we can enable differently
I mean just yesterday we had a two-day
hackathon on the other team where you
know like other technology companies we
give people 48 hours just hack a bunch
of stuff together see they've got new
ideas and within 48 hours we can build
something that's for example makes the
app understand whether you currently are
in an ER or urgent care clinic or a
physician and pops up new information
related to where you are and so that's
now a future we can build out and we can
double down on so that geolocation
figure but it can also tell you if I
been to Dunkin Donuts three times this
morning and you know be able to send you
a notice hey listen you got to watch
your carb intake it could I that's not
what we're doing right now but at some
point that might be possible as well I
you know a lot of future health outcomes
are as you said relate to behavior today
and so at least to give you advice not
to force you to change of your ways I
think that's that the latter one is a is
not a good place to go but they give you
advice and make sure your educators and
you have
some idea of how this will all affect
you that can be very helpful I think
do you have economists on staff is there
somebody sitting there doing the
modeling if I tell somebody and they
have a shorter ER visit it'll yield this
and that is there somebody who's doing
that kind of war game planning for
everything yeah we have a data team we
call the rest team that essentially goes
in and calculates which finely-chiseled
specialty a certain position is
performing in what the total cost the
key is when you go to certain Hospital
which sort of kind of behavior we see
you we say okay here do we have too much
our utilization here with too much
urgent care utilization that's all
happening in that seam and in fact
actually many of the member of the early
people in Oscar in the team came from
the hedge fund worlds and from global
macro hedge fund that have been thinking
applying this kind of thinking to the
global economy you know it's the
funniest feel that I'm in right if I
break my arm or my son breaks his arm I
can go to five emergency rooms and I
can't look up and say which is cheapest
which is the better outcome I just have
to go to one and in fact I have no idea
what it's going to cost until two three
weeks later when I get a bill yeah
so there's zero transparency and pricing
and in a sense hospitals can charge
whatever they want yeah
you obviously have an insight into the
data yeah so you have an asset here
which is you're starting to know what
hospitals charge what for what and is
that starting to guide decision making
yeah so as I mentioned about 40 percents
of all the first-time primary care
physician visits are now essentially
occurring after the member came to ask
her talk the concierge team looked in
the app looked in the website and found
that physician he or she wants to go to
work when members and go to these
physicians and we measure the total cost
of the akia over a longer period of time
then they go to physicians that on
average are about 10 11 percents cheaper
from a total cost of care perspective
then if they went to an average other
doctor in the same network there's a
better word inform less expensive less
expensive exactly and but glad you said
this because we can of course correlates
the costs and the total cost of care in
particular of that a physician is
driving to also quality of outcomes
member feedback as well and
every study out there and healthcare
that I'm sure you are familiar of as
well and also our data shows that there
is no correlation in the current system
or virtually no correlation between
quality of outcomes and then the total
caustic here hospitals can charge
whatever they want for the most parts
physicians often don't have the
information of whether they're driving
highly efficient total cost of care or
not and that is all something we can do
and so in a place like New York City we
can go to the physicians who show up in
our data both as driving happy members
and at the same time total lower total
cost of care we get them in deeper
relationships to us we tap into the air
and medical record systems and now able
to schedule appointments directly into
their systems we get more apartment
capacity with them directly in consent
members more to those physicians who
then end up making you happier ends
healthier at a lower costs and that's in
way already how the data work we've been
doing is really paying off in a you know
unique and in a meaningful way to you as
a member that's awesome well Mario thank
you for changing the health insurance
system in a positive way
thank you for collecting the data you're
doing to try to actually improve all of
our care and improve the system and I
think me and all the CBS News viewers
are very excited to see where Oscar
Health will go over the next six years
so thank you with visiting us today and
goodbye everybody